antes mas boa noite a todos é um prazer
enorme estar aqui pra vocês
agradecemos desde já o convite à
organização e ao ricardo gomes antes
mais gostava de vos dizer que trazemos
aqui duas músicas
há dois temas nós uma em inglês e outra
em português a não num num concerto
assim mais acústico não todos os
desenvolvimentos da banda
nós tivemos que nos adaptar a ocasião
espero que vocês gostem
[Aplausos]
[Música]
mas já soube
essa rio
[Aplausos]
ao uso bem não
eu dou que de ismar sou menina
[Música]
[Aplausos]
é realmente uma mãe
a mãe faz tio
saiu lindo as morning ganso
a auf aro nó ver que o frei e à velhice
não sei de nada que usam sim
o surfe
a tardeo foi feito
essa aí wang oishan
[Música]
mas venceu
elsa ribeiro da granja
a meu juízo
ó a pensar vai
o gol
o seu melhor
mas realmente uma mãe a um time ofensivo
a 1 mas quente o rei
já essa lona em que os
a fim
aro não
o órgão frio obviamente nem sei
ai que andar um cinto réu
um chopinho na to
é
mente am
é esse
[Música]
nery
ana nenhum
daniel
[Música]
é
nenê
o
[Música]
hum
o gol nada
[Aplausos]
acredito
love me
não sei
reza não se
um senhor fia a dylan foi
art
o pet e shows
é o museu frei de junho
[Música]
[Aplausos]
muito obrigado obrigado e tem que dizer
que a minha voz não está impecável
porque não foi do nosso povo mas foi
tratado assinado com o povo passou ontem
no estádio do dragão e eu tive que
empurrar em meio escolar o empregado era
ligado a um grande frisson no chat
unidades a ninguém mas haverá 10
nós lançamos o nosso álbum há cerca de
dois anos
foi uma jornada do muito trabalho
composto por dez temas com deus
este mesmo em inglês e o próximo tema
que vamos tocar a amm em português
chama-se tudo vai antes disso e por
falar em algum nós tivemos nós lembramos
de semearem os serviços propostos por
vastas mandioca já não conseguimos
colocar em todas mas espero que gostem
da surpresa para quem não teve a
oportunidade que tiveram cv
aproveito para dizer
aproveito para dizer que as nossas
músicas estão disponíveis nas
plataformas digitais no spotify youtube
e facebook e como é altura do natal a
chance de provar também dar um
presentinho online nessa já que o nosso
presidente foi estar aqui presente a fim
de fazer isso e sem mais mornas tudo vai
obrigar até a próxima
[Aplausos]
loooool
o gol
sinto pela noite em fase regional tudo
vai rolar e eu só tenho de equilíbrio
vou com vento
procuro mais que uma explicação
qual dos dois teria razão é igor vindo
nenhum vai entrar por um momento
tudo vai em tudo vai não sei se é
certeza mantém encerrada em que o
passado de frente como quem não quer
deixar esquecer o que tu vai tudo vai
bem tudo vai ao site e se alguém eo
pássaros bem indicou quem não te querem
já pensei o que convém 26 de poznan
entre o fundão
min em outro erro que não esconde que é
jeito
o que não vi
o livro que o vendo
procuro mais que uma explicação qual os
dois teriam nasal ou não vivo nem
ilusão que vai lutar por um
tudo vai nem tudo vai nos anjos chance
de ser campeã tem que ser alguém que o
cansados band ficou quem não quer deixar
esquecer o que convém não vai nem tudo
vai dançar
[Música]
vencerá guy que o passado de frente com
quem não quer deixar vencer pelo erro o
sol é um
se não for assumir a vaga não é proibido
porque o erro o sol é um
não vi é cor desculpa a ninguém
[Música]
é
an a
o lo
o gol
tudo vai bem tudo vai ser tenso
impotência ganham tudo vai bem tudo
hum
i junto vai lhe tudo
em xian certeza porque venceu o ganho do
provar
tudo vai no sangue
tudo vai bem tudo vai em san jose de 70
potencial e eu passado frente cocan
daqueles já esquecer o que que o vai
obrigado a todos foi no brasileiro
obrigado mais uma vez obrigado e boa
noite
continuação
[Música]